ja dort saßen sie also zusammen die
alliierten der ganze westen versammelt
dort ein machtvolles zeichen wir sehen
hier den breiten rücken von
us-verteidigungsminister von lloyd
austin und er hat er gestern paul einen
gewaltigen satz gesagt er hat nämlich
gesagt man werde himmel und erde in
bewegung setzen gegen putin himmel und
erde das ist schon so ein machtvolles
wort gewesen gegen putin wie man sich
das eigentlich seit wochen gewünscht hat
ja ja absolut und wie man sich es auch
endlich mal von deutschland wünschen
würde denn solche sätze wie hat man
nicht aus der deutschen politik gehört
man nicht von olaf scholz schon gar
nicht von christine lambrecht und die
amerikaner machen es mal wieder vor
denke ich wie man dort richtig reagiert
wie man eben nicht ängstlich ist von
putin wie man klare ansagen macht und
wie man das auch verbindet mit
waffenlieferungen die dazu passen zu
diesem satz denn ohne die amerikaner
glaube ich wäre kiew tatsächlich
eingekesselt worden ohne die amerikaner
würde es jetzt hier im don was sehr sehr
schwer denn sie sind am ende diejenigen
die dafür sorgen dass in der ukraine
genügend waffen sind jetzt haben wir
über diesen tisch gesprochen der
möglicherweise in sachen waffen in
sachen gewaltiges zeichen gegen putin
vereintes zeichen des westens gegen
putin eine tatsächliche wende bringen
könnte in diesem krieg jetzt gab es
einen zweiten tisch gestern in moskau
nämlich den langen tisch von putin deren
comeback gefeiert hat er saß dort mit
dem un-generalsekretär
frisch zusammen was war dieses treffen
wert wir sehen hier das bild dieses
treffen und wider dieser absurde tisch
an dem schon mal grob platz nehmen
musste olaf scholz platz nehmen musste
jetzt also der un-generalsekretär dort
die sechs meter entfernt von vladimir
putin was hat dieses treffen jetzt
gebracht also hat dass putin größer
gemacht oder war es was wert dass der
un-generalsekretär glasklar ein moskau
benennen konnte dass dieser mann der ihm
da sechs meter gegenüber sitzt ein
kriegsverbrecher ist
das war einmal vor allem wieder ein
lügen tisch geladen hat versucht die
verantwortung für botschaft für die
kriegsverbrechen von sich zu weisen
versucht das der ukrainischen armee in
die schuhe zu schieben das funktioniert
natürlich international nicht denn wir
waren da andere journalisten waren da
und haben foto poliert was dort passiert
ist
internationale organisationen haben das
getan das tut er natürlich für die
propaganda in russland also neben einem
un generalsekretär zu stehen und zu
sagen die ukraine sind schuld an
butscher das hilft vladimir putin
natürlich am ende allerdings muss man
sagen ist es doch noch mal ein
unterschied ob dort ein
un-generalsekretär kommt der auch über
bestimmte safe passage ist also sichere
wege raus aus mario pohl spricht nur
auch da lügt und
manipuliert wladimir putin und die armee
eben seit beginn des krieges sie tun so
als gäbe es diese wege dann werden die
wieder bombardiert
ja man will die menschen dort in
mariupol aushungern aber ich denke also
m generalsekretär darf man da
tatsächlich nichts unversucht lassen um
zu versuchen alles für die menschen zu
tun die dort eingeschlossen sind er ist
gerade seine aufgabe er wird weiter nach
polen reisen und am morgen dann auch
ukrainische präsident will ins treffen
lasst uns einmal auf eine region
transnistrien
das ist eine abtrünnige region in der es
jetzt mehrfach attacken gegeben hat
ukraine sagt das war nicht wie er das
ist eine provozierende aktion seitens
russlands was weißt du über diesen
vorgang dort
wir wissen auch nur das was wir in den
sozialen medien sehen was wir in den
medien sehen können transnistrien diese
region das ist dort möglicherweise eine
provokation russlands geben könnte um
auch dort in moldau weiter unfrieden zu
stiften
dennoch bleibt die frage so ein bisschen
mit welchen truppen eigentlich das ist
ja das problem leid ich mir putins dass
er hier schon so viele truppen verloren
hat eben beim versuch hier zu europa
beim versuch das ganze land damals in
tagen den wochen einzunehmen das nicht
funktioniert hat und jetzt will er ja
gerade im donbass vorstoßen bis zum 9
also wie dann parallel sozusagen eine
besetzung dort in transnistrien
passieren soll das erschließt sich mir
noch nicht so ganz danke an unseren bild
reporter unterwegs in der ukraine
weiterhin danke an pofalla